Good Lord.
I thank all of you for coming
out to London for Playtime.
This is my first Playtime, so
I'm kind of a rookie at this.
But I've been making
games for a long time,
and I absolutely love this.
This is one of my
favorite topics,
talking about the
games that engage us
on a daily, monthly, weekly
basis that keep us all playing
and coming back for more.
So this is one of
my favorite topics.
And it's an absolute
honor to be here talking
to you guys about this.
So thank you all for coming out.
And again, in case
it wasn't obvious,
my name's Adam Gutterman, I
work on the business development
team at Google Play.
And I focus on game
design and consulting
with developers on promoting
the best game design, best
practices on the platform.
There we go.
So here's the agenda today.
First, we're actually
going to define engagement,
because it's a pretty
straightforward topic,
but there's a couple
of distinctions
that I want to make
just to kind of level
set-- make sure that we're all
talking about the same thing.
And then we're going to
talk about probably the core
component here, actually
designing games for engagement.
We're going to talk about
Google Play game services,
which the way that Ben and
John described it just now,
it's quite obvious.
It is a tool box for creating a
great engagement for your game.
It is literally all the
tools that you'll ever need.
And then number
four, we're going
to talk about community,
because community is very, very
important-- the way that you,
as developers, engage users
with your game.
So what is engagement?
I think everybody here
probably knows how
to measure engagement for sure.
I mean, we talk about
retention rates, D1, D7, D30.
And certainly one
way we figure out
how people are engaging
with their game,
if they're sticking
around and playing.
We talk about sessions per
day, session length as well.
And there's another
one that we talk about,
which is like a stickiness
factor, which is Daily Active
Users over Monthly Active
Users-- DAU over MAU--
it's a percentage.
But what is
engagement in essence?
We know how to measure
it, but what is it?
There's actually
kind of two types
that I want to talk about.
First type is direct engagement.
And this is the one that we see
on a pretty much daily basis.
And it's kind of
the obvious one.
It's when people are
actually using your game
and playing your game.
This is a game called Two Dots.
This is right after
I finished level 123.
This is direct engagement.
It's very straightforward.
It's everything players
do while directly
interacting with the game.
But there's a second type--
and we'll get to that later--
but I just wanted
to call it out now,
because it's also
very, very critical.
I call it community engagement.
Now think about it this way.
Think about your hobbies.
And this is really interesting.
I came up with this example
before I saw the opening video
that came out before Purnima
kind of gave the opening
keynote this morning.
I thought about this
example about fishing.
And there's apparently
an incredible fishing app
out there, which is exactly
the type of thing that
drives community engagement
with a hobby of fishing.
So it's actually
really well timed.
And it's one of those
moments of synchronicity
I couldn't have
planned any better.
So for example, when I
was a little bit younger,
I was visiting my hometown
of Houston, Texas, which
is right on the Gulf of
Mexico and the United States.
It's a great little fishing
town right outside of it
called Galveston.
And my friends and I decided
one night let's just go out
fishing, because it was
just a nice beautiful night
and we went out, and we did it.
We caught a 10-kilo
fish last 10 minutes
we were out on the ocean.
And honestly, it was
one of the best nights
I've ever had as a fisherman.
That right there, me
telling you this story
and talking about it, you
engaging with that app
that we showed earlier
today in the video, that's
community engagement.
It's everything that
you do when you're
engaging in a hobby or a
game when you're not actually
engaging in the
hobby or the game.
When I'm out casting
my reel or when
I'm out playing Two
Dots or some other game,
that's direct engagement.
The second type is
community engagement,
but it's equally important.
We'll get to exactly why later.
Designing games for engagement.
So we've defined exactly
what engagement is.
Now let's talk about
how to design for it.
And I could go through
game after game after game
after game, and tell you
exactly how these games are
designed for engagement, but
that wouldn't be super helpful.
So I've decided to
kind of narrow it
down to three
games-- three games
that I've been playing for a
very, very long time, three
games that are all
very, very different,
three games that have
been out actually
all for about the same amount of
time-- about a year and a half
and are all very, very
successful on Play.
Those three games are Two Dots.
Who here has played two dots?
Raise your hand.
Yeah.
Like 50% of you, I love it.
There's another game.
It might be a little
bit more US-centric.
It's called Family Guy
Quest for Stuff and TinyCo.
Hands?
A couple of you.
Love it.
No.
Few of you.
I love it.
OK.
And the last one is
going to be Hearthstone.
Who's played that
game from Blizzard?
Yeah.
OK.
About the same
number as Two Dots.
Fantastic.
These three games are amazing.
They're all very,
very different.
Two Dots is pretty much
as casual of a game
as you can get.
TinyCo is Family Guy's
kind of a builder, very
much like a SimCity game, kind
of in that mid-core range.
And Hearthstone is
almost as core of a game
as you see on the platform.
So tried to pick three very,
very different games and game
design, style, genre
across the board.
So let's talk about these
games and how they're designed.
This is Family Guy
Quest for Stuff.
I found this image
on the internet,
because it's quite descriptive
of how this game has
been engaging for so long.
This is a year's worth
of content in the game.
We're a year and a half in,
but this is exactly one year
of content in the game.
And the cycle for how this
game is operated and run
as a service.
As TinyCo releases new content,
players build the content.
They experience it.
It's a builder game.
It's kind of like a SimCity
or game or a FarmVille
or something like that.
Players build the content.
They kind of go
through it and then
they have the content
in their beautiful city.
And then TinyCo
releases more content.
Players experience it, build
it, and kind of go through it.
And this cycle continues
on and on and on.
And TinyCo kind of has
to go through this cycle
very, very quickly--
every couple of weeks
release new content.
And I call it, not
pejoratively, because I really
love these games, but I
call the content furnace.
And the furnace, the
way it burns things up.
The reason I call
it a content furnace
is TinyCo ships this content and
then players kind of experience
it.
They burn it up.
It's just kind of like you're
putting coals in the fire
just to keep the fire going.
And if you were to stop
putting coals in the fire,
that furnace would
kind of die off.
It's one way to keep
players engaged,
but it's very, very resource
intensive and very resource
heavy.
And in that way, the
content furnace actually
doesn't scale very well.
My content furnace, another
way I want to say this,
it's kind of just
single player content.
One piece of content equals
one piece of engagement.
Once you kind of
experience it, you really
can't experience it again.
It doesn't scale very well.
So the question is,
when you're designing
games for engagement-- this is
one model-- but what scales?
How can you get more
bang for your buck
out of your development hour,
your development dollar?
Here we go.
Let's take a look at this
example from Two Dots.
Half of you have
played this game,
so I don't need to explain
exactly what this game is
about.
But it's-- for those of you who
haven't-- it's a match game.
It's not unlike Candy
Crush or Cookie Jam.
And matching games actually
are very much content furnaces
in their own.
Cookie Jam and Candy Crush each
have over a thousand levels,
which is an incredible amount
of content, each meticulously
designed and balanced.
Two Dots itself has over 400.
So there is definitely
a content furnace here.
They release new levels.
Their most highly
engaged players
will go through them
very, very quickly
and then just kind
of wait around.
Come on, guys.
Release new levels.
There's definitely
content furnace here.
But the story doesn't end there.
Here is the most
interesting part.
So again, this is my
score on level 123.
It's 242.
I got one of three stars.
And here's my little face
on the leaderboard here.
My friend Aaron actually has
a higher score than I do.
And I'm beating Eric.
So what can I do?
I could go on and
play level 124,
continue to burn
through the content--
because it's a content furnace.
But the subtle thing
that's going on here
is I'm being encouraged to
actually replay this level, two
different ways in fact.
I'm encouraged to go ahead
and get a higher star
rating, achieve this
higher star rating,
which is set by the developer.
I'm also being encouraged
to go ahead and beat Aaron
and his little smiling
face, because he's
kind of taunting me right
there with his high score.
So chasing that
personal achievement,
like a three-star
rating or trying
to beat a friend's high
score, these actions
actually drive repeat engagement
with the same type of content.
This actually scales.
And hence, in this way,
replayability of your content
is what scales.
This is the key message here.
If you want to get more
bang for your buck,
for your development dollar,
for your development hour,
replayability of your
content is the key.
One unit of content, instead of
equaling one unit of engagement
like we saw with
the TinyCo example,
it equals many
units of engagement.
Now we talked about, on
that previous slide--
let's go back to it real quick.
This achievement
here-- the three
stars-- it's kind of
a limited achievement.
Once I hit it, I'm
actually not going
to want to try to hit
that again-- once I
hit my three stars.
But the leaderboard here.
Let's say I do go back, and I
try to beat Aaron's high score.
And I beat him.
Maybe I post on
Facebook, or Twitter,
or email him directly or
just run into him and say,
hey, man, I beat
your high score.
Well, he's probably going
to be encouraged to beat me.
But maybe then Eric
gets in on the action.
And this could go on back
and forth and back and forth
and back and forth
for a very long time.
So whereas this personal
achievement up here
which is set by the developer
of getting up to three stars
is something that's kind of
a limited thing, high scores,
in this type of competition,
infinitely scales.
So we talked about
how replayability
is what actually gets
things to scale in general.
Multiplayer competition--
competition in general-- scales
forever and scales infinitely.
Honestly, we could be fighting
over a high score on this level
forever.
And you saw this back in the
early days of arcades, back
in the '80s when
people would go--
fighting over high scores and
their arcades and Pac-Man.
And it still happens today.
It's a similar system.
So I promised I would
talk about Hearthstone.
Here's a Hearthstone tournament.
It's got this rich set of
multiplayer competition going
on right here.
It's kind of amazing.
Hearthstone has been around
for a year and a half,
and it doesn't seem to
be slowing down at all.
The question you might
ask yourself, well,
should I just ship
multiplayer to my game?
Is that kind of
the magic bullet?
Well, it's certainly
a good starting point.
What else can you
do to actually drive
success of that multiplayer.
It's a bit more subtle than just
kind of let's shit multiplayer
and see what happens.
Hearthstone has actually
architected their game
in a very specific way
to drive engagement
for a number of different
users across a number
of different levels and with
different types of cadences
as well.
So let's take a look at that.
This is what I see
when I first log in
to play Hearthstone,
Daily Quests.
I can win two games as a mage,
or a shaman, or a paladin,
or a warrior.
And if I went
through all of these,
I can earn all this
gold-- 140 gold here--
is what it would total up to.
And these carts would
refresh themselves
at the end of the
day after 24 hours.
So I can come in
and kind of fill out
these quests on a daily basis.
Very cool stuff.
They released a
feature pretty recently
called the tavern brawl.
When I took this screenshot,
it actually wasn't available,
but I decided to stick
with this one just
to kind of show off
the cadence of it.
It's a Wednesday through
Sunday competition.
At the end of Sunday, the
rewards are kind of tallied up,
and your placement in the
tournament is kind of shown.
But it's a weekly tournament.
And I got to come back in
the day to start this one.
So this type of action
here, it's a daily thing.
This one is a weekly thing.
This is a screenshot from the
March 2015 season in the play
mode, level six, top 3%.
Does anyone want to guess
if this was me or something
that I pulled off the internet?
I pulled it off the internet.
I'm not this good.
I wish I was this good.
I finished 10 once.
But yeah, this ranking here
that you see March season 2015.
It's a monthly ranking.
So we had daily quests.
We had weekly tournaments.
We have a monthly ranking.
And see what they're doing here.
Let's look at how
they design this.
They've got many modes of
play with their multiplayer,
including solo play.
They've got solo adventures
in the arena, which you
can pick up and play anytime.
It's available for anybody.
This is your anytime,
always-on content.
You have your daily
quests, rewards
that you get on a daily basis
for engaging with the game.
You have the tavern brawl,
weekly competitions.
And you have the play mode for
the most core users competing
for that monthly ranking.
You see what they're doing here?
They're designing
their multiplayer--
they're designing their entire
game around the multiple ways
that people want to
engage with their game,
whether it's on a daily
basis, a weekly basis,
or a monthly basis.
They're looking for
any way to cater
to a user that has a
particular way of wanting
to engage with the game, whether
it's super casual or super core
or somewhere in between.
I think this is
absolutely brilliant.
So we've talked about
quests in this game.
We've talked about
multiplayer competitions
in all of these games.
We've talked about leaderboards.
We've talked about achievements.
All this should sound
pretty familiar.
We just heard her
talk about all of it.
It's Google Play Game Services.
Play Game Services is 100%
a tool box for developers
to develop all these
amazing features,
which keep people
engaged in your game
throughout the life of the game.
And I pulled these images
from the Play Games
app, which by the way has
over a billion installs.
And you guys should
open it today
if you've never opened it.
It's a beautiful app.
And it's the way
I kind of manage,
the way I game as a player
on our platform, right?
Open the app to see
what's going on.
Let's take a look
at these things.
We've got leaderboards.
This is the game I
play called Threes!
It's one of my favorite
casual games out there.
Doug is a much better
player than I am.
I'm second to him.
I'm certainly incentivized
to go ahead and try
to beat his score.
Here's another very, very
popular game on our platform
called Boom Beach.
I've got about 48%
of the achievements.
And I am slowly
working my way up.
I know that John and Ben
are doing better than I am.
And Quest, for
example, here's a game
from PennyPop
called Battle Camp.
Anytime a new quest
shows, it shows up here
in the Play Games app.
And I'm very much encouraged
to go ahead and play it.
And we also have multiplayer.
We have term-based and real-time
multiplayer matchmaking
that you can plug right into.
And that's kind
of the key thing.
We talked earlier about getting
the most bang for your buck
out of your development dollar
for your development hour.
You can go ahead and build all
this stuff if you would like,
but you know, to be
frank, Ben Frenkel kind of
made it very easy
for all of you guys.
You can plug right
into our services.
You can plug right into
achievements, to leaderboards,
to multiplayer.
It's all right here
and ready to go.
It is the tool box that you
need to drive engagement
with your game.
There it is.
So let's go back to this
image of Hearthstone.
It's a beautiful
looking terminal here.
Lots of people playing.
I don't even know
how many screens
that we have here, like 10
screens there or whatever.
But notice there's a lot
of people that are actually
not playing
Hearthstone, and there's
a viewing screens up there.
This is community engagement,
this tournament itself.
People are playing and
watching and talking about it.
They're not actually playing
the game, all of them.
These people, as
we defined earlier,
they're engaged in
community engagement.
Why is this important?
You might have seen one
of these in the past.
This is a pretty typical
marketing 101 marketing curve.
This is tracking the adoption
of a product over time.
You've got your innovators,
your early adopters,
your early majority, late
majority and your laggards.
If you've read a
Malcolm Gladwell's book,
you've definitely
seen this as well.
Now here's the thing.
The people that influence
other people to download games,
to go fishing, to buy a
magazine, to try a restaurant,
those people are
actually involved
in community engagement.
And they're the influencers.
They are the
influencers, the mavens
that you always hear about.
And they actually kind
of reside over here.
They're the most engaged
people in whatever product
you're talking about.
This applies to just
about any industry.
That's why this is important.
When you get people
talking about your game,
when you get people posting
on various social medias
about your game, when
you get people creating
YouTube videos-- anything
that pretty much,
again, falls into that category
of community engagement--
that's so critical, because
community is actually
an engagement and marketing
channel for your game.
And this is the critical thing.
User acquisition is incredibly
expensive these days.
Sometimes it costs
upwards of $15
to get a user onto a platform
or on pretty much any platform.
However community
engagement-- the fact
that it can drive new users
to your game for free--
it's incredible.
It's one of the
most powerful things
that you can do to drive
long-term engagement, long-term
acquisition with your game.
One last point I'd like to
make about social engagement.
And I wish I knew which
community manager I was talking
to when I heard this, but it's
really, really interesting.
It's kind of a very,
very critical point.
We've been talking a lot
today about getting the most
out of your development
dollar, your development hour,
because we're all
resource constrained.
The thing about community.
You can develop your
community in real-time
without bothering an
engineer, without bothering
an artist, without
a product manager,
without going
through a QA cycle,
without pushing out a
release on Google Play,
without going through
a review process.
You can develop your
community in parallel,
in real-time as your
game is being developed.
It's kind of an obvious thing.
But it's also a very,
very critical thing.
Your community is always on.
It's always engaged.
And you can always be doing
more to engage your community.
And again, you
don't have to kind
of work with your development
team, and kind of slot things,
and kind of fight for resources.
Your community manager
or your community team
is completely independent.
And that's a pretty
critical aspect.
One last thing about community.
We've talked about community
in sort of that online sense.
I've shown images of Twitter
feeds and talked about YouTube
and things like that.
But probably the best way you
can engage with your users
is in real life,
directly, one-on-one.
So I want to give
the example of Glu.
I've been working with Glu
for a very, very long time.
And they've got two of the
biggest games on our platform,
Racing Rivals, which is
the number one racing
game on our platform, and Kim
Kardashian Hollywood, which
I'm sure you all are
very familiar with.
They've done community events
which I think are quite unique
and kind of display the power
of what community can really
bring to the table.
Let's look at Racing Rivals.
Again, Racing Rivals has been
around for many, many years.
It started out as a Facebook
game, and now it's on mobile.
And it's got a cohort
of users that have just
been playing this
game and collecting
cards for many, many years.
They're very, very
passionate about the game.
They spent a lot of money.
They're super engaged with it.
They're gear heads as
people like to say.
People who are really into
cars are really into this game.
So the studio down
in Long Beach,
as they were kind of developing
the next suite of features,
they thought to themselves,
well, you know what?
We've got a core group of people
involved in this game that
should probably have a
little bit of input as
to what we develop next.
Because you look at the roadmap
of things you could develop.
You could develop
it in a vacuum,
or you can do what Glu did.
They flew out to
Long Beach-- 20 or 25
of their most highly
engaged players--
and had a round table
discussion about what should we
do next in Racing Rivals.
And they talked about it.
They kind of scoped it out.
And they essentially
turned their community
into game designers.
And I guarantee you, when all
those guys and girls flew back
to their home states
and home cities
or whatever, they
probably spread
the gospel about Racing
Rivals and said, listen,
I had this amazing experience.
So I went out to Long Beach,
and sat with the Racing Rivals
team, and helped
them design the game.
And I guarantee you,
beyond just engaging
those players and their friends
in a deeper, deeper level
in the game, that word spread.
I'm spreading it
to you right now.
This right now is community
engagement in Racing Rivals.
Similarly with Kim Kardashian,
they had a contest in the game
and flew out some of their
most engaged young players
in the game to meet Kim.
They didn't talk
about game design.
It was just a meet-and-greet.
But I guarantee you, every
single one of those people
that flew out and
met Kim, myself
included-- you can look at
pictures later on my phone
if you would like.
Come find me later.
I wasn't allowed to
put them up here--
I guarantee you every
single one of them
is spreading the
gospel about this game.
This kind of IRL, real
world community events,
where you meet your consumers,
and you talk to them directly,
and you get their feedback,
this is the most powerful type
of community engagement
you can really drive.
And it pays back in spades.
That's all I have for you today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]